madame monsieur bonsoir bienvenue au 20h
fin de la solidarité entre les membres
français de l'arche de zoé la soeur d'un
des condamnés dénonce aujourd'hui les
mensonges du président de l'association
eric breteau ce dernier apparemment
affaibli a dû être hospitalisé au sein
de la prison de fresnes you soon groupe
est désormais incarcéré au pakistan le
caïdat n'y être à l'origine de
l'assassinât de benazir buttho la
version officielle donnée par le pouvoir
ne satisfait d'ailleurs pas non plus les
partisans de l'ex premier ministre qui
ont continué à manifester aujourd'hui
dans ce journal nous verrons pourquoi le
risque de chaos au pakistan peut menacer
l'équilibré de la région mais aussi du
monde entier
l'espoir plus que jamais en colombie ce
soir les hélicoptères qui doivent
récupérer les trois otages libérés par
les farc sont à moins de 100 kilomètres
du point de contact
tout est prêt ils n'attendent plus que
le feu vert de la guerrière
une bonne nouvelle pour ceux qui ne
savent pas faire la cuisine il paraît
que les progrès au rayon surgelé
permettent aujourd'hui de faire un
excellent réveillon sans se fatiguer
démonstration dans ce journal
buren aubure à le sculpteur envisage de
démolir ses célèbres colonnes au palais
royal à paris si elles ne sont pas
restaurée l'artiste dénonce l'inaction
de l'état pour protéger son oeuvre
on commence avec le retour des six
français de l'arche de zoé deux
informations ce soir d'abord le tribunal
qui doit transcrire leurs peines en
droit français se réunira à créteil le
14 janvier prochain
à cette occasion tout le monde sera
définitivement fixé sur son sort mais en
attendant le retour sur le sol français
à délier certaines langues et à
semble-t-il mis fin à la solidarité du
groupe
reportage rites de la mort né paul
hinder dit vincent kelner
dans sa valise quelques affaires pour
son mari pour endurer la prison ce matin
l'épousé du dr van winkelberg est l'une
des premières arrivées à fresnes c'est
la première fois qu'elle va revoir son
mari carrière au bourget elle ne l'a
même pas entraperçu les militants de
l'arche de zoé avaient prévu un comité
d'accueil criant à l'injustice et
oubliant un peu vite les conditions
rocambolesques dans lesquelles
l'association a agi le boeing tchadiens
se pose mais les détenus sont évacués
par une sortie militaire de l'aéroport
loin des regards
aujourd'hui leurs familles ont enfin pu
les rencontrer à plusieurs reprises
l'administration pénitentiaire a fait
preuve de souplesse
la plupart des membres du groupe sont en
cellules classiques mais eric breteau
est à l'hôpital pénitentiaire
il est dans un état de santé critique il
a perdu 20 kilos elle pleure et pourtant
la loire et de l'allier mais la
solidarité du groupe affiché jusqu'ici
se fissure
il critiqué comment tout a été fait
comment toute la manipulation peterson
et quand il poser des questions quand il
est arrivé qu'ils poser certaines
questions c'était toujours très évasive
et il a vu des choses qui n'ont pas lieu
d'être je lis tu n'as rien commandité il
ne doit pas être la même enseigne que
que le cerveau de l'opération qui fait
un boulot
certainement bretonne
dans ses mains une enveloppe à
l'intérieur les confessions de son mari
qu'elles promettent explosive
quoi qu'il arrive la sphère ne sera pas
rejugé
ni apple ni cassation si la peine de
huit ans de travaux forcés commués en
huit ans de prison les condamnés ne
pourront sortir qu'à mi peine en 2011
pour sortir plus tôt seule solution une
grâce du président tchadien ou une
libération conditionnelle parentale pour
ceux qui ont un enfant de moins de 10
ans dernière piste un nip haute éthique
appel à la cour européenne des droits de
l'homme
quarante morts en deux jours la tension
ne retombe pas au pakistan après
l'assassinât de benazir buttho menée du
côté de l'anc est la version officielle
donnée par le pouvoir n'a rien apaisé
bien au contraire
al qaïda ni être à l'origine de cet
attentat et les partisans de l'ex
premier ministre s'interroge désormais
sur les conditions réelles de cette mort
bernard les bras le dernier meeting hier
que s'est il passé jeudi après midi 27
décembre à la fin de cette réunion
politique de feu benazir bhutto
tout se déroule autour et à l'intérieur
de cette voiture blanche un 4 4 blindés
à toi ou moi
première version du gouvernement avec à
l'appui cette vidéo je cite madame
boutons se serait elle-même mortellement
blessé derrière l'oreille sur la poignée
du toit ouvrant de sa voiture en se
roulant à l'intérieur du véhicule du
fait d'une explosion fin de citation
voici le même document de meilleure
qualité en effet benazir buttho sortie
par le toit salue ses militants dans la
rue centrale de rawalpindi
voyez au ralenti le passage important
madame butô et toujours à l'extérieur du
véhicule dans le cercle rouge
le pistolet de l'assassin tire déjà
voici la même scène à vitesse normale
avec le son
quatre coups de feu après seulement une
bombe explose en dans la foule du tireur
il ne reste que le pistolet tel quel les
faits donnent plutôt raison à la famille
bhutto qui parle dans son fief dollar
canadien assassinat et de la trace de
l'impact visible lors de la toilette
mortuaire d'une balle en pleine tête un
assassinat qui pour l'opposant du
gouvernement nawaz sharif que l'on voit
ici justifie le boycott des élections
mais le gouvernement pakistanais ne
partage pas du tout cette opinion je
pense que c'est un débat tout théorique
que de savoir comment elle est morte et
il est bien plus important pour moi que
le peuple puisse apprendre qu'il a tué
pas al-qaïda selon son porte-parole
local qui osait affirmer ce matin ne
jamais tué de femmes alors qu' une
certitude la moitié du pays et en colère
et accuse le président musharraf où les
islamistes d'avoir assassiné ou laisser
assassinée benazir bhutto
depuis deux jours plus de 45 personnes
sont mortes dans ces émeutes et des
millions de dollars de bâtiments publics
sont partis
en fumée mais sur place on retrouve
maintenant notre envoyé spécial philippe
rochot philippe vous êtes à islamabad la
capitale du pakistan
quelle est l'atmosphère là bas ce soir
moi je dirais que ça ressemble à une
atmosphère de couvre-feu même si le
gouvernement n'a pas pris cette décision
d'ordonner aux gens de rester chez eux
mais les gens le font quand même ils
restent chez eux parce que d'abord il
n'y a plus d'essence pour circuler il
n'y a pratiquement plus d'électricité
sur la ville les liaisons aériennes
intérieures ont même été interrompue
peut-être qu'elles reprendront demain
mais vous voyez le pays est vraiment en
crise et les gens sont obligés de se
contenter de vivre à la maison et de
parler bien sûr de cet attentat alors
philippe pour sortir de cette crise on a
beaucoup aussi parlé des élections
législatives elles sont prévues pour le
8 janvier prochain
il semblerait ce soir qu'elle puisse
être reporté quel est l'enjeu de ce
scrutin exactement et connaît pour
l'instant le président musharraf
maintient toujours ces élections au 8
janvier ce qui est assez stupéfiant
parce que les gens ici nous disent mais
ces élections elles auront quelle
signification
le principal opposant politique benazir
buttho a été supprimée physiquement
nawaz sharif qui était le numéro deux de
l'opposition on peut dire a appelé au
boycott de ces élections donc finalement
le scrutin qui va sortir de là ne sera
absolument pas représentatif de
l'électorat pakistanais donc pour
l'instant ces élections sont maintenues
quelques jours avant elles peuvent être
encore reporté mais il faudra beaucoup
de temps pour que on reconstitue ici un
véritable et chevaux politique qui avait
été sérieusement détruit par les
attentats de ces derniers jours
merci philippe alors on vous parle
beaucoup du pakistan depuis deux jours
depuis cette tête cet assassinat de
benazir butto
la raison en est très simple ce qui se
passe dans ce pays peut avoir des
conséquences non seulement dans la
région mais aussi dans le monde entier
regardez cette carte pour mieux
comprendre le pakistan s'est un peu plus
de 169 millions d'habitants tous ou
presque musulman avec une particularité
le pays possède l'armé atomique comme
son voisin et ennemi indien et le
problème c'est que si le cas où devait
s'installer bien beaucoup redoutent que
l'arsenal nucléaire ne tombe dans les
mains des terroristes d'al qaïda tout
proche
depuis la guerre d'afghanistan tous les
chefs talibans dont probablement oussama
ben laden sont réfugiés à la frontière
avec le pakistan
jérôme bernard
avec ses 169 millions d'habitants le
pakistan est le deuxième état musulman
du monde après l'indonésie en 60 ans
d'existence cette république islamique
n'a jamais connu de démocratie stable
une seule et simple raison à
l'indépendance les britanniques n'ont
laissé aucune institution derrière eux
un boulevard don pour les militaires qui
depuis dictent leur loi quitte parfois à
s'appuyer sur les fondamentalistes à
leurs risques et périls pakistan l'enjeu
pour la région le pakistan est un état
stratégique à l'est
l'inde l'ennemi héréditaire détenteur
lui aussi de l'armé nucléaire
les deux états se disputent depuis des
années la région du cachemire
à l'ouest c'est l'afghanistan une zone
très instable depuis 30 ans pakistan un
foyer islamistes à la frontière des deux
pays
cette région poreuse qu'islamabad n'a
jamais pu contrôler les zones tribales
un refuge terroriste fait pour cela que
les etats-unis mènent une guerre sans
merci et que washington a dépensé 10
milliards de dollars pour aider le
général musharraf mais dans le même
temps le pouvoir pakistanais laisse plus
les madrassas les écoles coraniques où
l'islamisme radical prolifèrent pakistan
le danger nucléaire
aujourd'hui la crainte numéro 1 des
occidentaux c'est que l'armé nucléaire
l'une des 50 aux gifs à kista neige ne
tombe entre de mauvaises mains
beaucoup pensent que l'armée reste
encore le dernier rempart contre le
chaos mais on l'a dit fragilisé est
infiltré par les islamistes
nom de code emmanuel l'opération de
récupération des trois otages en
colombie a débuté aujourd'hui dans sa
première phase désormais les délégations
internationales se trouve à moins de 100
kilomètres de leur objectif
deux hélicoptères n'attendent désormais
plus que le signal de la guérilla un
signal qui se résume en quelques
chiffres ce décor données satellitaires
pour récupérer les otages dans la jungle
jacques cardoze
ils n'attendent plus que le feu vert des
farc les hélicoptères du comité
international de la croix rouge ont pris
position sur l'aéroport de villavicencio
en colombie ce sont eux qui doivent
rapatrier les otages eux qui doivent se
rendre quelque part dans la jungle à
destination de ce point de rendez-vous
tenu secret et que la guérilla marxiste
ne délivrera qu'au dernier moment
nous espérons que la deuxième partie de
cette opération humanitaire va pouvoir
débuter nous espérons pouvoir présenter
rapidement à la presse et à la
communauté internationale une opération
pleinement réussi l'interlocuteur des
farc n'est autre que le président
vénézuélien hugo chavez celui qui aime à
se montrer devant les caméras
jouant les libérateurs nous avons réduit
les risques au maximum à présent nous
avons bon espoir que clara comme souhait
la mg ml soit très rapidement chez eux
en colombie les familles attendent
nerveusement ce dénouement heureux
insupportable attente malgré tout elles
se veulent optimistes
tout est prêt maintenant tout a été
étudié et si ce n'est pas pour
aujourd'hui je suis sûr que c'est pour
demain selon le gouverneur de la
province colombienne concerner toutes
les conditions semblent réunies pour que
l'opération soit menée à bien
tout sauf une le feu vert des par tim
pied de nez aux états unis apparemment
hugo chavez ne peut pas s'en empêcher
le président vénézuélien s'est offert
pour cette opération les services d'un
des symboles d'hollywood
le réalisateur oliver stone sera dans
l'hélicoptère avec sa caméra pour un
remake de plateau une version jungle
colombienne
ce dernier a été autorisée à filmer
toute l'opération il faut dire que le
cinéaste américain ne tarit pas d'éloges
sur hugo chavez c'est un grand homme dit
il
je suis ravi de participer à cette
aventure at il ajouté les organisateurs
du dakar ont décidé finalement de
maintenir les étapes prévues en
mauritanie et des récentes attaques
terroristes perpétrés dans le pays avait
pourtant de quoi inquiéter
mais les autorités mauritaniennes ont
affirmé que la sécurité serait assurée
pour les participants elle prévoit tout
de même de déployer pas moins de 4000
militaires et agents civils sur le
trajet hakim abdel khaleq la menace
d'une annulation du paris-dakar planer
après la mort cette semaine de quatre
touristes français un quadruple
assassinat signé al qaïda selon les
autorités mauritaniennes
la traque des trois tireurs est toujours
en cours un suspect en possession d'une
grenade a été arrêté au mali jeudi ce
sont trois soldats mauritaniens qui ont
également été tués dans une attaque
terroriste dans le nord du pays
arrivé jeudi en mauritanie les patrons
du paris dakar ont multiplié les
contacts avec les autorités locales
le parcours a été minutieusement étudié
aucune étape n'a été supprimé ou modifié
nous avons prévu de passer huit jours en
mauritanie
et si nous n'étions pas que convaincu
que la mauritanie fera ce qu'il faut en
terme de sécurité
c'est le dakar même qui pouvait être
remise en cause pour sécuriser le rallye
4000 hommes vont être mobilisés dans le
pays
deux mille militaires en uniforme et
2000 agents civils
la menace terroriste a déjà plusieurs
fois planer sur le paris-dakar en 2004
deux étapes au mali et au burkina faso
avait été annulé et en 2000 un pont
aérien avait été mis en place pour
éviter une étape dangereuse au niger on
va revenir maintenant sur une
information qui avait fait très
longtemps la une des journaux
cela fera cinq ans jour pour jour demain
cinq ans que le centre de sangatte près
de calais a été fermé il accueillez vous
le savez les clandestins candidats une
vie meilleure vers la grande bretagne
alors on est on aujourd'hui les
problèmes ont-ils été résolu celle en
quête de cette édition et les signaler à
palau et dominique maes toujours le même
chemin le long des voies ferrées pour
être plus discrets
malgré tout dans calais les migrants
sont aujourd'hui bien visible cinq ans
après sangatte près de 400 personnes
viennent ainsi chaque jour attendre le
repas livrés par les associations à
gauche et africains à droite les afghans
irakiens et kurdes
deux fils pour éviter les conflits
nadine in la jl ça lui prend des
nouvelles depuis 2001 à l'interprète et
informé qu'ils ont des seins sur les
dangers du passage en angleterre pour
elle depuis la fermeture de sangatte
rien n'a vraiment changé continue à
rêver au effectivement et continuer à
rêver et on leur envoie du rêve donc
malheureusement oui je viens de bagdad
c'est vraiment difficile là bas il y a
beaucoup de problèmes et de danger je
veux absolument aller étudier en anglais
et ce rêve a attiré 70 mille migrants
pendant les trois années d'existence de
sangatte à une dizaine de kilomètres de
calais le centre d'hébergement géré par
la croix-rouge a littéralement implosé
au fil des ans
puis ce fut la fermeture en 2002
inévitable pour nazi lui d'avoir comme
ça quelque chose en bordure de
frontières comme ça c'était pas évident
et puis c'était il ya quand même aussi
que 14 douche on est monté à des
populations de jusqu'à 1800 ingérable la
situation est toujours cinq ans après
l'immigrant se pressent dans cette
permanence de soins pour des gal grippe
et parfois tuberculose et vu les
conditions sont très difficiles très dur
parce qu'il fait froid ici je dors dans
la forêt donc c'est vraiment dur pour
moi je pense qu'il faut quelque chose
pour les accueillir
la preuve en a supprimé sangatte et il
ya toujours presque autant ils sont dans
la rue ils sont dehors peut-être
auront-ils un hébergement si les
températures descendent en dessous de
zéro comme la semaine dernière en
attendant les ombres des migrants
continuent d'errer dans les rues et sur
le port de calais il ya parfois des lois
que personne ne respecte saviez-vous que
l'utilisation des feux d'artifice est
interdite dans les grandes villes en
france le soir du 31 décembre
voilà qui fait sourire quand on armement
aller réveillon précédent et cette année
n'a aucune raison d'être différente
à paris par exemple la vente qui est
officiellement prohibé depuis le 15
septembre bien la vente peut se faire
nous l'avons constaté sylvain le petit
arnaud juste si vous êtes parisien voilà
ce que vous n'aurez pas le droit de
faire le soir du 31 décembre à paris
comme dans certaines grandes villes de
france
les préfectures interdisent
l'utilisation de feux d'artifice et de
pétards
dans la capitale la vente en et même
suspendues depuis deux semaines enfin en
théorie plus beau feu d'artifice
vous voulez quoi comme types de feux
d'artifice un truc qui peut être bien
les couleurs qui polluent
ce client va dépenser 460 euros pour
illuminer son réveillon au grand bonheur
du vendeur pas très au fait de la
législation
on n'a pas été prévenue effectivement de
cette interdiction de cet arrêté
autre magasin même discours ici on vend
tout type de pétards même si on
reconnaît que certains comme ces
mortiers sont dangereux mal utilisé et
ça peut blesser les gens parce que
l'yonne il ya des galopins qui se sont
amusés à prendre ce machin allumé la
mèche et avisé carémeau là les ordres de
police où les voisins est classé marron
la fête est ouverte pas fait et on va
réveiller la voisine mais avec
l'effectif qui se déclenche
nous avons donc pu acheter morty et
fusées gros pétards pour les montrer un
artificier et ses pétards contient à peu
près 5 grammes d'explosif
si vous ne pouvez tenez à la main
lorsque ça fonctionne vous pouvoir la
main très bien aussi bien par les faits
l'éclatement que par l'effet de chaleur
ça montre très hautes températures
jusqu'à 3000 degrés pour ces feux de
bengale alors si vous organisez un feu
d'artifice respecter les normes de
sécurité
chaque année 150 personnes sont blessées
et en parlant de réveillon les stations
de ski ont fait le plein cette année
pour sa deuxième semaine de vacances les
alpes affiche complet ou presque
vous étiez nombreux cet après midi à
prendre votre location comme on dit
reportage à valmorel arnault compte
thierry magnier relier planter de bâton
et premières sensations
il y a ceux qui n'ont rien perdu de leur
technique et ceux qui ont comme en dire
le style un peu rouillé naissance
ça fait mal aux cuisses perdu l'habitude
on va bien sûr j'ai pas ce qui depuis 18
mois puis j'ai jamais très bien ce qui
est moi ce matin sur la route cet après
midi sur la piste
certains ne perdent pas une seconde pour
goûter la neige l'athlète la première
bonjour mr cascades mais on n'a même pas
encore la porte on est on au fil de la
journée le direct via boys les bonnes
très bien avec un 4 2 face aux problèmes
de verglas l'est là impeccable chez vous
il fait frais y aura de soucis mieux que
l'année dernière
derrière il ya pas grand chose à ses
vrais
aujourd'hui la station était rythmée par
les chassés croisés ces jeunes lillois
viennent d'arriver pour fêter le nouvel
an avec eux toute la panoplie du bon
montagnard
qu'est ce qu'il faut pas oublier quand
on vient au ski et bats la bière surtout
pour cette dernière semaine de l'année
les vacanciers ont envahi les stations
de ski il faut dire qu à valmorel comme
dans la vallée tout le domaine est
ouvert un excellent début de saison pour
les professionnels la semaine de noël
est rempli à peu près 80%
c'était très fractionnée et puis pour la
semaine qui s'annonce
elle s'annonce vraiment bien puisque les
taux de réservation sont à 100% neige et
soleil bref le bonheur et ce ne sont pas
les enfants qui vous diront le contraire
autre destination prisée pour ses fêtes
new york plus que jamais cette année les
français se sont rués outre atlantique
n'y voyez pas un geste politique un
quelconque soutien de george bush non
pas du tout la raison est bassement
matérielles avec un euro aussi fort face
au dollar
jamais la grosse pomme n'avait été aussi
bonne à croquer martine laroche-joubert
car geoffrey on signe le temps la statue
de la liberté battait le record des
files d'attenté des touristes français à
new york
aujourd'hui changement de cap avec
l'euro pour boussole
ils se pressent devant les boutiques à
la mode on est arrivés vers 9h15 sachant
que le magasin ouvre à 10 heures il y
avait déjà une que 200 mètres et à 10h01
le de plus 300 mètres de long ça nous a
mis pas de faire la queue quand même
pendant 45 minutes
c'est comme une attraction euros durant
l'euro de plus en plus fort face au
dollar changent leurs repères
bouleverser les usages et dope leur
moral
quand on a eu l'habitude d'un dollar est
fort agréable de venir dans une ville
qui finalement est moins cher qu'à paris
pour qu'on arrive à le freiner dans ton
que pour faire les magasins c'était
vraiment vêtements électronique new york
pour les heureux détenteurs d'euro se
transforme en caverne d'ali baba
un conte de fées moderne à la caisse que
vous avez acheté ben ali peu de 80 gigas
par rapport à la france est presque
il y avait trop de différence une
frénésie d'achats mais pas de folies
les français ne se voit pas encore un
flambeur et garde pour la plupart leur
sang froid devant les vitrines des
grands joailliers
vous avez envie d'aller c'est fini oui
mais font plaisir des yeux à l'assaut de
choses permettant un accès très choisis
c'est beau à regarder alors les français
sont-ils tiraillé entre l'envié de
consommer grâce à l'euro ou le goût de
se cultiver
devant le musée d'art moderne la
réconciliation ce que vous préférez
faire des courses ou aller with et on
fait les deux il faudrait que la
faiblesse du dollar ont fait bien sûr
beaucoup de courses et puis on fait les
musées parce que les choses à voir
on peut pas voir en france avec l'europe
hors france et joue les droits à new
york au paradis des communes nous
envient qualité à nos de la fille
certains le vivent comme une angoisse le
réveillon du jour de l'an approche et
comment faire pour recevoir quand on ne
sait pas cuisiner et bien n'en déplaise
aux puristes la solution existe
aujourd'hui au rayon surgelés il faut
dire que les progrès les efforts des
industriels dans ce domaine sont réels
et ces derniers la firme un bon
réveillon à surgelés ne refroidira pas
vos amis outre m un projet de leur dire
laurence de cherves chloé cormery pour
les livres de recettes ces directions
cartons dont quatre jours la famille
déménage alors pas question de perdre du
temps et de jouer au chef cuisinier le
menu du réveillon de la saint sylvestre
sera donc surgelés de l'entrée au
dessert on a choisi des petite mise en
bouche pour l'apéritif les gambas les
noix de saint jacques
si gratin de pommes de terre sans
oublier les légumes les aubergines et
petit fagot de haricots verts les
petites entrées comme ça c'est vraiment
bluffant vous mettez s'assurera du fun à
l'afp son site un traiteur qui est venu
qui est venu présenter tout ça pour le
leader du surgelé le chiffre d'affaires
double pendant les fêtes
chaque année la gamme des produits
festifs change la moitié des ventes sont
des produits élaborés inventé ici par
des cuisiniers pour le chef la
surgélation d'aujourd'hui n'altère ni le
goût ni la texture vous n'avez pas de
création de deux choristes ont atteint
un produit qui fait qu'en fait on
restitue exactement le poids du fait
qu'il a été sur 250 à raison les moyens
en petits morceaux
une fois validé la préparation sera
fabriqué industriellement et surgelés a
moins 80 degrés une technique qui permet
toutes les audaces
que ce soit dans les couleurs dans les
textures les associations je n'ai pas de
contrer la surgélation pour moi est un
moyen de vous de conservation près de la
moitié des achats de surgelés se fait en
grande surface alors les distributeurs
se sont lancés dans ses produits de fête
avec leurs propres gammes est un atout
le prix on a des gens un canapé pour au
prix de 2,5 euros 90 en termes de
rapports quelque chose de bien pour mes
clients un réveillon surgelés qui ne
s'annonce pas forcément plus cher qu'un
réveillon fait maison destinée aux
flemmards et à ceux qui aimeraient bien
profiter aussi de la fête
on va rester dans le coup avec la grande
mode de l'huile de lit depuis que l'on
sait qu'elle est bonne pour la santé on
la sert presque à toutes les sauces
c'est bien que les producteurs en france
ne savent plus comment augmenter leur
production
ils investissent à tour de bras la
consommation a tout simplement été
multiplié par quatre en 20 ans reportage
alliance aux portes de la provence
caroline thébaux claire-marie dany
comme des pièces d'or qui tombe du ciel
car ici les olives prennent tous les ans
de la valeur cet agriculteur avait
multiplié son chiffre d'affaires par dix
en dix ans pour ses 3000 arbres
il a investi sur cette nouvelle
technique de récolte plus efficace ils
ont les leviers sont récoltés comme ça
de pris
une veine quand et j'ai pas l'impression
qu'ils sont malheureux
c'est sûrement un massage pour eux une
fois tombés près de l sont encore
bichonner d'envoyer une olive par terre
on s'arrête dans la fin
chacune est précieuse safin est
précieuse et respectée car toute la
commune mise aujourd'hui sur cet or vert
deux jeunes pompiers sont plantés chaque
année et un nouveau moulin a vu le jour
un investissement de 3 millions d'euros
les olives sont triés lavés puis tout
est broyé même le noyau de a à z
la température y contrôler mais c'est
très efficace
on a remplacé le moulin traditionnel à
mal de pierres par un moulin moderne
parce que c'est important pour nous dans
la traçabilité dans le fruit la qualité
des produits sains produits
d'appellation contrôlée haut de gan bien
gardé voilà nous rentrons à la salle de
stockage de l'huile d'olive c'est notre
coffre-fort se représente 260 1000e
litres d'huile d'olive et environ 3
millions d'euros cette huile va se
vendre 20 euros le litre cinq fois plus
cher que lui l'espagnol un goût unique
estime voilà la forme la forme ouverte
c'est la croisette
fraîchement coupée car pour être
rentable l'huile d'olive française se
vend aujourd'hui comme un grand vin une
question maintenant combien y at-il de
chevaux en france drôle de question et
pourtant l'administration français se la
posent et personne ne peut y répondre
résultat la loi va obliger tous les
propriétaires à recenser leurs animaux à
partir du 1er janvier prochain
un recensement électronique grâce à une
puce placée sous la peau de l'animal
les ânes sont aussi concernés même si
cela fera beaucoup de monde disent les
mauvaises langues indiqué pj la delage
le 1er janvier
ce cheval de selle français sera dans
les règles grâce à une petite puce
électronique pas plus grosse qu'un
grainerie poser dans l'encolure par une
simple injection encore l'étranger qu'on
introduit donc c'est les tissus qui
forment un kyste au tour elle ne devait
plus se déplacer
cet appareil permet de lire le numéro de
la puce l'identité à vis du cheval un
contrôle sur et rapide par exemple pour
les compétitions lever tôt quand on
présente notre cheval le veto qui fait
le contrôle vétérinaire qui l'a tout de
suite son lecteur est ce qui fait que
bon systématiquement il sait que c'est
le bon cheval
la puce est déjà obligatoire pour
participer aux concours et aux courses
objectif éviter les fraudes
l'identité des chevaux mais au 1er
janvier tous les équidés devant la porte
et y compris les espèces rares comme
ceux baudet du poitou
car les papiers de l'animal ne sont pas
une garantie il y avait des papiers
comme ça voilà c'était le papier qui
pouvaient qui pouvaient trafic est
malheureusement au club pour vous la
puce c'est une garantie supplémentaire
puces c'est une garantie
c'est une garantie à tous les niveaux
tous ces numéros sont répertoriés dans
un fichier des haras nationaux avec le
matricule on peut retrouver le
propriétaire utile en cas de vol mais
ils sont encore nombreux à gambader dans
les prés sans identité électronique plus
de 100 milles sur environ un million dès
qu'il est en france on va parler d'un
autre animal maintenant vous le
connaissez tous vous en avez peut-être
même vu sur les plages à marée basse
il s'agit de l'art et nicole sever des
sables pas particulièrement plaisant à
regarder intéresse de plus en plus les
chercheurs pour la qualité de son sang
imaginez que cette bestiole que vous
étiez peut-être prêt à écraser pourrait
un jour vous sauver la vie
laurence beauvillard et les cuire pouf
on pourrait croire que ce sont des
pêcheurs en quête d'amour pour leurs
vignes pas du tout ce sont des
chercheurs de la station biologique de
roscoff
il ramasse un drôle de vers l'art et
nicole les étonnantes capacités de
survie de ce ver ont intrigué francazal
et son équipe
dans un premier temps si d'un point de
vue purement fondamentale on essayait de
comprendre comment le faire respirer
dans l'air et dans l'eau
ce que vous voyez qui si donc les
animaux sont à sec par contre ils vont
se retrouver quand la marée va monter
vont se retrouver sous l'eau et on
essayait de comprendre en fait comment
c'était possible comment un mécanisme
physiologiques comme ça pouvait
fonctionner c'est dans le sens de ce ver
que la réponse se trouve leur
hémoglobine est capable de piéger
l'oxygène et de le conserver plusieurs
heures et plus étonnant encore leur
hémoglobine ressemble étrangement à
celle contenue dans les globules rouges
de notre sens ce chercheur à imaginer
que tout ce sens pourrait peut-être
servir à l'homme
la première application que l'on vise à
réaliser en fait c'est d'utiliser cette
molécule dans la préservation d'organes
donc augmenter la capacité la durée de
vie des organes ratant de
transplantation la seconde application
c'est en fait d'utiliser cette molécule
dans des pansements actif qui permet en
fait d'oxygéner l'été et d'améliorer la
cicatrisation et la troisième
application c'est d'utiliser cette
molécule comme substituts sanguins
mais ne rêvons pas pour transfuser du
sang d'art et nicolas l'homme il faudra
attendre plusieurs années
par contre dans deux ans il devrait être
utilisé pour les greffes d'organes dans
quatre à cinq ans pour les pansements
les organismes marins sont de nouvelles
pistes très prometteuse et de nombreux
scientifiques cherchent dans l'océan
notre salut de demain pour une tentative
c'est une réussite le navigateur
français francis joyon semble bien parti
pour battre le record du tour du monde à
la voile en solitaire
il a passé le cap horn la nuit dernière
avec plus de neuf jours d'avancé sur le
précédent record détenu par la
britannique ellen macarthur
le récit de cet incroyable aventure avec
christophe duchiron en quelque sorte en
doublant le cap horn hier à la nuit
tombante francis joyon le tourdumondiste
a mis un petit coup de clignotant à
gauche c'est pas grand chose un coup de
clignotants ça fait tic-tac
mais là c'est énorme car il en a terminé
des mers du sud c'est mère de tous les
vices
la pression d'échapper au grand méchant
loup du grand sud
vraiment on revient dans une ère connue
atlantique
mieux qu'un tour du monde c'est une
cascade de records que joyon n'en finit
pas de faire tomber à la barre de son
fidèle trimaran qui l'accompagnent en
course avec un sens aigu de la
performance 35 jours pour atteindre le
cap horn c'est 9 de mieux qu ellen
macarthur et oui c'est vrai que
avec année commence à être un petit peu
rouillé je pense que le bateau avait
jeté sur mon mieux croire tolère encore
tout frais il lui reste un tiers du
parcours à effectuer mais la maison se
rapproche elle est juste après l'horizon
et l'incroyable exploit à portée
d'étrave il ya décidément des oeuvres
dont le destin est de faire scandale
après avoir dû se battre pour installer
ces colonnes dans la cour d'honneur du
palais royal à paris
le scripteur buren pousse maintenant un
coup de gueule comme on dit pour les
faire entretenir
ils dénoncent ce qu'ils appellent le
vandalisme de l'état inactifs et
envisage lui-même leur démolition si
rien n'est fait marylène bono marais
cazaux ça ces dernières secondes avant
que l'on soit carrément volé d'ailleurs
pour rien parce que c'est plus 10 abl
vous avez ici il ya même plus de bordure
du tout et on avance on a la même chose
c'est normal sur un pièce public à
chaque croisement ici
il y avait des plots comme on les voit
là bas c'est plomb des drh est jamais
remis et tout est tombé en court-circuit
il ya déjà au moins huit ans il est très
en colère daniel buren ces colonnes ont
résisté autant jamais à gainey
vandalisés depuis 22 ans
en revanche l'entretien des lieux des
fondations et du système électrique a
été négligée depuis des années ce matin
daniel buren l'expliquer aux visiteurs
au premier abord on n'a pas l'impression
que que ça bouge en coin et puis après
dans le détail là on me colle à l'abîmé
bond par rapport aux choses très graves
c'est le moins grave le plus grave c'est
qu'il n'y a plus d'eau plus doux dans la
fontaine depuis huit ans et c'est devenu
pour l'artiste une véritable poubelle à
ciel ouvert pour quoi on a un trou par
exemple et rien qui se passe ça devient
absurde cette espèce de trancher s'il
n'ya pas l'eau qui couvrent dessous il y
a deux ans le ministère de la culture
avait chiffré le coût des travaux à un
million et demi d'euros
depuis plus rien et les promeneurs
continuent à venir ici chaque jeu valeur
un petit peu à l'abandon va dire même si
les enfants grimpent sur les colonnes il
ne les abîmes pas c'est un vaste terrain
de jeu qui suscite toujours la curiosité
j'aime beaucoup et c c'est trop grave
pour faire des photos c'est très sympa
selon le ministère de la culture la
rénovation globale du palais royal est
programmée d'ici 2011
en attendant vous peut récupérer
l'argent dans la fontaine et commencer à
économiser musique pour terminer voici
une voie que vous avez forcément déjà
entendu à la radio c'est l'une des
révélations de cette fin d'année
elle était un top model mais s'ennuyer
d'être trop belle alors à la voulu
chanter et tout le monde se les arracher
c'est frais c'est vers ces micky green
elle est australienne et c'est un
français qui l'a découverte
olivier les noy's à matthew beard n
comme dans un rêve mais l'apparition à d
avoir accueilli des fêtes attire voir
attend un du lait
micky green souris verte en france est
très petite souris né il ya 23 ans en
australie vit aujourd'hui à paris
la pop possède son top pendant quatre
ans micky green fait la une des
magazines des fils à new york le milan
une existence bien remplie mais une vie
vide
c'est là que tout commence
hatcher
entre deux séances photos micky green
passé son temps à écrire composer les
maquettes enregistré sur son ordinateur
bimbo séduisent de producteurs de manu
chao
c'était une surprise pour moi de
décrocher un contrat
j'avais déjà toutes les chansons c'était
bizarre de les entendre une fois
enregistrés en studio c'est là son
disque est saluée par l'ensemble de la
critique la musique passe en boucle à la
radio les chansons de son deuxième album
sont déjà prêtes car micky green ancien
mannequin ne veux pas être un phénomène
de mode
ce journal merci de l'avoir suivi je
vous en rappelle l'un des principaux
titres
les six français de l'arche de zoé
s'apprêtent à passer leur deuxième nuit
en prison à fresnes
ils y resteront au moins jusqu'au 14
janvier date à laquelle le tribunal de
créteil va transcrire leurs peines en
droit français
a priori elle ne pourra pas être
inférieure à celle prononcée par les
tchadiens soit huit années
d'emprisonnement
les familles entendent bien faire appel
mais entre elles les premières fissures
commencent à apparaître
la soeur d'un des condamnés dénonce
aujourd'hui les mensonges du président
de l'association eric breteau c'est tout
pour l'actualité tous samedi tout de
suite vous avez rendez vous avec
nathalie rihouet pour la météo à 20h50
france 2 vous offre un panel de stars
les stars de l'année 2007
depuis pour ma part je vous retrouve
demain dès 13h excellente soirée sur
france 2
l'info en continu est aussi sur france 2
pourrait faire
tous